[Applause]
oh my God I'm so thrilled that you're
all here I I feel like a lot of the time
you get to speak to one person who's
involved in a project but not you know
the whole uh family which you're going
to have different perspectives which is
a lot of what your film's about right
family and different perspectives and I
just knew out of the gate when I was
watching it I was like this is someone
this is it seemed tell me if I'm correct
very personal for you that's exactly
right yeah um and yeah thank you for
saying that yeah so yeah Finn plays a
character who is like
um a rock star online he has 20 000
followers around the world from Belarus
to Bangladesh and his mom is she runs a
domestic violence shelter yep and the
two of them have like a clash of of
culture generation and values okay uh
Finn I'm so excited to talk to you I
actually got to hang out with Millie
Bobby Brown
um she did the show but I heard recently
um that she was talking about on-screen
kissing with you um and she was teasing
uh that you were lousy yeah
you've got like brother and sister like
you and Noah and her have grown up
together you have raised each other in
certain ways like how did you feel about
your family member calling you a lousy
kisser yeah you know what my first uh
like on-screen kiss was with Millie
um and so but I didn't know how to like
approach that in any way and there was
no just was like you're gonna do this
thing and at the end of the take you're
gonna kiss her and then so I just like
kind of just like almost like head
butter yeah and then but then yeah yeah
the romantic way of putting it was that
yeah I had butter well I I've had to
kiss a lot of people uh over the years
it's very mechanical
um and I was excited because I was gonna
kiss my boyfriend at the time on screen
Luke Wilson and I was like this is going
to be great and then he kissed me in the
scene like
and I was like I thought this was going
to be different yeah yeah and I was like
oh that's so weird he gave me the pursed
lips yeah yeah yeah I even give open
mouth you know yeah okay well I just
have to talk to you about that because I
I feel like it's a weird thing on screen
kissing is a weird world okay Alicia
used to write screenplays based on
movies is this true yeah it's no it's
not really impressive at all so
basically oh my God oh my gosh oh my god
wow so basically I was obsessed with the
Cheetah Girls movie and apparently
a lot of fans so they made the movie
into a book you could buy a Barnes and
Noble and read it with pictures in it
and stuff then I took that book that was
already a movie and made my own like
wrote it up myself and made my own
screenplay and made my friends act it
out but it was already it was just so
what is unimpressive about that it's I
mean like because it was already in film
no he's just so smart thank you drew
that's amazing to me that's what you're
going for that's exactly what I was
going for yeah all right so so what was
it like to work with Jesse as a director
I loved it I was extremely intimidated
at first because I was I was a fan of
you of course
yeah like the least intimidating person
yeah I know and then I met you and
that's a picture of the least
intimidating person who's still a human
being I think it would look like I'm
honestly intimidated by All actors I
feel like they're I mean you just want
to you you meet people you meet other
actors and you want to be challenged and
you want to
um just drop into the space and feel
really comfortable and I was just
nervous it was like the first time I'd
worked in a year because this was 2021
January and I've been like cooped up in
a house and I was just nervous all
around and then Jesse just made me feel
so comfortable and was so open to
collaborating well you did a wonderful
job uh helming and leading this
beautiful story about humanity and
families and what's important to do with
a life and figure that out along the way
and take care of other people because I
was like what does the title mean and
when I saw the film you get it um we
have a clip of when you finish saving
the world uh let's take a look at it
please you don't have to be interested
in politics
but I am no you're not it's obvious but
it's it's cool
you think I'm stupid
no no I didn't say that
so can you teach me
about what
I want you to talk about things
like
like big things
and you talk about them with such
passion
and Alicia Beau when you finish saving
the world is in feeders tomorrow
[Music]